ces images ont près de 25 ans elles sont
l'oeuvre des comédiens du tnp eux mêmes
il ne s'agit pas d'une rétrospective de
l'histoire du festival d'avignon mais
plutôt d'une sorte d'album de famille
que nous vous proposons de feuilleter
ensemble gérard philipe n'est plus jean
vilar est mort cet hiver mais leur
festival demeure
nous avons voulu les faire revivre pour
vous quelques instants
jean vilar et gérard philipe avait rendu
les noms du tnp du festival d'avignon
célèbre au bout du monde
nous les retrouvons ici en tournée près
de prague
partout il demeurait une équipe de
copains et la moindre plaque de neige
était prétexte à bataille jean vilar
fuyant sous les boules de gérard philipe
mais quelle image pourrait rester plus
émouvante que celle de la mort du prince
de hombourg